dihora c'est plus laïque la solde de
l'angleterre
alors moi mon personnage c'est charlotte
robespierre mousser la soeur de
robespierre une révolutionnaire est très
engagé en fait dans la politique et dans
les droits mais en même temps qui a
envie d'avoir une sorte de grande
souplesse eu accès c'est la dernière
fois que je te fais un cadeau
pourquoi dis-tu ça parce que le pen
appelle le tortueux que je dois faire
pour toi mon adversaire est flottant
dans les batteries et moi je suis une
grande fan des visiteurs j'adore ce film
ce que les répliques entières
donc j'étais super flattée en même temps
que tu espères inquiet je les ai vus
suez avait juste pas tu t'appelles
jacques cool on te faut quitter paris
plus souvent verdier si tu veux mieux
comprendre les doléances et les
aspirations de nos compatriotes et
régions